[Musique]
il y a la reconstitution d'abord
funéraire où on vénère le fait qu'on ait
déposé le corps de Jésus dans une pièce
super étroite il y a la place pour
quatre personnes généralement les
pèlerins qui ont se mettent à genoux ont
du mal à regarder autour d'eux parce
qu'il y a les icônes des uns les
tableaux en argent des autres toutes les
églises de Jérusalem ont des cierges à
l'intérieur des candélabre tout ce que
vous voulez et puis surtout on vous
laisse relativement peu de temps à la
vénération parce que le tourisme de
masse fait que vous êtes le temps d'une
courte prière dans l'édifice avant de
voir sortir donc effectivement
ridicule actuelle le tombeau de Jésus
le sommet du christianisme le lieu de la
résurrection est un tout petit peu
troublant pour le regard
[Musique]